[Music]
[Applause]
so I need a haircut and normally I would
go visit my barber Yosef Yosef charges
17 dollars for a haircut today I'm doing
some very different I'm going to the Ted
Gibson salon Ted Gibson is a celebrity
hairstylist on the reality show what not
to wear I'll be right back
he's done here for Angelina Jolie Keira
Knightley and Hathaway also charges
$1,200 for a haircut crack down against
an eye how do you do so tell me a little
bit about here I haven't loved my
haircut in a really long time and I
wanted to come and see what you could do
with it here I think eyes always say it
changes everything
I never hear anyone say they have a bad
skin day they always say they have a bad
hair day so after I cut it I want to
make sure that every day for you is a
good hair day and then you're really
good about yourself so you can
accomplish anything that you want to in
your life my biggest concern is always
less to do with my hair but more how it
interacts with the shape of my head
absolutely because I feel like I get
like I'm Ted Kennedy what I do for the
Ted Gibson experience I'm gonna give you
a massage on your shoulders the back of
the neck and your head
abduction clean I'll bring you back and
do your haircut and then you know we'll
have a little bit more dialogue about
who you are and what you want to be when
it comes to the tickets as long that's
what it's about it's not just a haircut
right and good anywhere to get a haircut
the reason why I decided that I wanted
to raise my product at $1,200 I spend an
hour and fifteen minutes or an hour and
30 minutes with each guy I do my own
shampoo right I'm with you the entire
time or you're not handing I'm not
handing you from person to person to
person so I figured that that that level
of service has a price tag
you know girls - they love to be able to
say you know I got my hair cut by Ted
Nixon and you know what he canceled his
appointment on me because he had to go
through an Angelina Jolie yeah yes it's
never actually massage my hands where I
usually get my hair tied
Oh Angelina which scent did you like for
your hand massage I like prosperity how
did you oh your affirmation I don't want
to look in the mirror yet I want to wait
for my big moment I want to wait with it
for the payoff over that's the moon well
that looks great oh yeah I do the ride I
feel ridiculously pampered I feel a
little almost boozy
[Music]